This is you, this is your family tree and
this is Your Family Tree Explained.
You have parents, and your parents have
parents. These are your grandparents, who also
have parents - your great grandparents.
Keep adding parents, keep adding "greats".
For every "G" in the name there is one
generation in between you and that person.
Grandparents? One "G", one generational
in-betweener.
Great, great, great grandparents?
Four G's, four in-betweeners.
Continuing with the basics, you have siblings,
and so do your parents. These are your
aunts and uncles.
Up the tree, you may call these people your
great aunts and uncles, but your grandparent's
siblings are also your grand aunts and uncles.
Greats are reserved for the levels above grand.
Your great grandparents' siblings are your great
grandaunts and uncles.
Now down the tree, your siblings' children are
your nieces and nephews, collectively - niblings,
and you are their aunt or uncle.
Their children are your grand nieces and
nephews, and you are their grand aunt or uncle.
We've gone up and we've gone down, and it's
time to go sideways.
When you get married, you get everyone's
favorite in-laws. You are on the same level of
the family tree as your spouse's siblings.
You are kind of "pseudo-sibling". All the new
families'
relationsips to you are the same as to your
spouse,
but they get the in-law prefix [suffix].
It's pretty straightfoward except for one case:
Your spouses' siblings are your siblings-in-law
but are your siblings in-law spouses also your
siblings-in-law? It's a little unclear.
Alright, enough with the in-laws, it's onto the
reason
you're probably watching this video. Cousins?
Your aunt's and uncle's chidren are your
cousins,
but there are many kinds of cousins and to
better understand them we need to
simplify this family tree, and think downward.
Here is you, your children and your
grandchildren.
Your grandchildren are your first cousins to each
other,
and their children, your great grandchildren,
are second cousins to each other, and so on.
The cousin number is the same as the "G" rule:
it tells you how many in-betweeners until the
connection
on the family tree.
Fourth cousins? Four in-betweeners, and a
shared
great, great, great, grandparent.
According to the rule, your first cousins
and you connect at your grandparent.
And second cousins share a great grandparent
connection.
Just match the cousin number with the number
of G's, and you are all set. Simple!
Side note here: Continuing this rule in reverse,
means that siblings can technically call each
other 0th cousins, which they totally should,
and you are your own -1 cousin? Weird.
(Side note end)
All done here now, nothing more to talk about ...
oh right, the once removed thing.
You may have noticed these cousins are on the
same level.
Removed just describes how many generations
apart people are.
For example: what's the family connection
between these two?
Start by taking the smaller cousin number
first cousins, and count the levels apart, once
removed.
These are 1st cousins twice removed, thrice removed.
And these are second cousins, once removed.
Doing all this on our simplified drawing of your
descendence is a bit too easy as most family
trees look
more like this.
The rules are still the same - first cousins, second cousins and the removed,
but it is a bit harder to tell quickly who exactly is
your second cousin twice removed or your great grandaunts-in-law?
To help, there is a chart you can download
which will both make it much easier to figure out
what grandnibling or cousin removed are to anyone at
the next family reunion and obviously, show
how cool you are.
Now we're really done. Unless, you start thinking
about the math of all of these family members.
Just how many great, great, great, great granparents
do you have? 64?
And those ex-grandparents had kids giving you a whole lot of cousins.
This chart happens to stop at 10th cousins
of which you have more than 2,000?
Which seems like way too many,
but these numbers both have big, possibly unsettling asterisks
attached to them, which we will talk about more
in Part 2: Family Genetics Explained.
CC by Luka.